yeah I mean he looks good I saw pictures  of him yesterday like everybody else  with the blonde hair so you know blonde  hair vibes so it's a bit very cool I  just want to see now how many other  people are going to be getting their  hair colored blonde because you know the  trend start with that family and move  down so I actually have an appointment  tomorrow to get my hair bleach no I'm  just kidding approve of a blondie like I  think it's fun so it's a fun come back  for me I think it's cool and different  and you know Kanye definitely is a trend  setter for everybody from from high  fashion to street where he sets the  rules and everybody else kind of just  does their own version of them and  follows them  [Music]